that's
not a meal hey everyone i'm abby sharp
welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's video we'll be catching back
up with miss remy ashton and taking a
look at what she eats in a week but
first let me tell you about my sponsor
storington hall so starrington hall is a
really fun online game that's based
around the green family and their
inherited old mansion it has honestly
been such a great way to unwind on
stressful days that still feel somewhat
stimulating and fun basically you play
for the youngest daughter jane and you
get to solve all of these really
interesting puzzles related to other
characters secrets and betrayal if you
like home decorating that's in here too
so you actually get to furnish the house
and plant the garden exactly to your
style and my personal favorite part is
dressing up the characters and throwing
fancy balls in parties it is like
strangely satisfying to get to match
their costumes with their hair and
jewelry and you don't have to like pay
for it in real life it's also possible
to play with friends by inviting them
through facebook and then you can tackle
some of the match 3 levels as a team so
if you want to try out storington hall
yourself you can install the game using
my link in the description or scan the
qr code on the screen and get a bonus
for new players infinite lies for six
hours and you can pause the screen or
look at the description to check out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating so as
always feel free to skip this video if
it's not supportive to your journey and
if you are not already subscribed hit
that subscribe button and follow me over
on tick tock and instagram at abby's
kitchen so if you recall during our last
review remy was on a weight loss journey
while managing her pcos so her diet was
inherently pretty low calorie and low
carb she seemed to bounce between kind
of like clean eating and engaging in
cheat day mukbang like behaviors which
you guys know i don't feel are super
conducive to long-term health so in this
video from april 2022 remy challenges
herself to try to save some money by
cooking more often at home because she
like so many of us has been relying a
lot more on takeout and delivery during
the pandemic so let's start off by
looking at one of remy's money-saving
healthy breakfast hacks for the week i
am going to do one of my favorite
therapeutic activities and that is
juicing so i just spent some time and i
prepped all of our ingredients that
we're gonna juice tonight we have seven
juices this will last cow and i a little
bit over three days it tastes great
makes me feel good i love it also like
one of these containers in la would be
the price that it was to make all of
them so doing it at home is just so much
better and again therapeutic okay so i
know you guys all think that i hate
juice but i actually love it when it's
presented like this as remy says juicing
her own produce for the week is
therapeutic it tastes great to her it
makes her feel good and it saves her
money
in motion so if your juicing ritual is
rooted in self-care intuition and
enjoyment rather than diet culture and
pseudoscience it's exactly what we love
to see i'm also a meal prepping fan in
general so it makes sense to make a big
batch of juice since it does kind of
feel like a big production to do i do
want to point out though that
unpasteurized fresh produce juice like
this will start to slowly lose
nutritional content over time
potentially as early as like 30 minutes
after it's pressed now i think it's well
worth the added convenience because
slightly dulled nutrients in batch
prepped juice is certainly better than
no nutrients because you don't have time
to juice daily but i would say that most
fresh juice should only be kept in the
fridge for three days or so like she
said now this yummy looking juice often
makes an appearance in remy's breakfast
throughout the week combined with a
piece of fruit and a go macro bar a
yogurt cup or a couple hard-boiled eggs
with coconut aminos another day she just
has an apple and a peanut butter packet
because she's on the go and in a rush in
general i love that we're getting some
micronutrients in our green juice and
usually some source of fat and protein
in the nut butter eggs or bar but i will
say most of the time we're looking at
between 10 to 15 grams of protein which
is a solid start but i think we would
find if we bumped this up just a little
bit we'd feel a lot more saturated and
energized between meals we know how
important hunger crushing combos are for
everyone but they're particularly
important for folks with pcos or blood
sugar management issues so if it were me
i would suggest combining some of these
breakfast components together like
having the eggs and the yogurt or the
nut butter and the eggs and that's just
going to help to amp up the protein
intake i actually think her best meal of
the week was her kind of later brunch
style breakfast where she had eggs and
vegan sausage for protein half an
avocado for fiber and fat and an air
fried hash brown for some carbs that
looked like a super sustaining morning
meal and also pretty delicious now let's
talk about snacks
so again this week was all about cooking
the foods that she loves and craves that
she would often just door dash in and as
we know cooking from scratch often takes
time so i love that if a meal prep was
taking a little bit longer than usual
and she was hungry remy would honor her
hunger and have like a little appetizer
as a snack sometimes it's like a simple
steamed dumplings or microwave soup
dumplings sometimes it's the batch
prepped hard-boiled eggs and sometimes
it's something super convenient like a
store-bought pudding and i love that
sometimes you just need a little
pre-meal appy to take the edge off so
that you can sit down and enjoy your
meal without the hangry drama it's also
obvious to me that remy's able to listen
to her body when she doesn't feel that
she absolutely needs to finish
everything that's on her plate or in her
glass case in point this amazing looking
iced latte with rice crispy treat
creamer
that sounds insanely good i made myself
a latte this is a double shot espresso
latte with almond milk and rice krispie
treat coffee creamer rank in my coffee i
don't know what it is i can never finish
a coffee drink please let me know if you
are also the same i know but there are
actually some days that even a coffee
addict like me has like a sip of coffee
and my body says no and even though my
brain is like i want this it's coffee
time and i love coffee time i find it
actually feels punishing to drag myself
through a food or drink when my body or
like just my mouth is turned off it so i
appreciate remy's intuition on the
coffee front let's be real the first sip
or bite of anything will always taste
the best now let's move on to lunches so
we've got a really nice assortment here
of some more convenience foods and
homemade meals all of which look really
delicious and simple leftovers seem to
be a strong lunch theme which we love
there's really no reason to spend an
hour in the middle of the work day
making lunch when you can just easily
double your dinner prep the night before
so one day she made a big kale salad the
night before for dinner and topped the
leftovers with some shrimp for protein
nuts and parmesan for fat and avocado
for fiber and fat as well another day
was a leftover piece of toast crinkle
fries and chicken tender and aioli and
for a home prep day she air fried up
some chicken wings and served it with a
protein dip and on a busy day she
managed to like snatch her besties meal
prep which was some jerk white fish and
green beans all of these lunches sound
amazing but i would say in most cases
they seem a little bit low carb and i
know she's pcos and so she's probably
been conditioned to keep her meals super
low carb to control her blood sugars but
for all of you at home you know working
to manage your blood sugars for various
reasons i want you to know that carbs
are not the devil but be warned
satan knows me big we can absolutely
still enjoy carbs at every meal or snack
we just want to choose mostly higher
fiber options or pair them with a solid
amount of protein and fat so the salad
for example looks amazing but we could
easily make this into a more satiating
meal with like a whole grain pita or
roasted sweet potato in the mix ditto
for the jerk chicken and green beans
which i'm not sure was like a very
satiating full meal even a piece of
fruit on the side would have been a
fiber rich energizing choice now the
chicken wings on their own probably seem
like a very light meal but they did have
a soup dumpling starter to kind of like
build that out and the protein in the
chicken and the dip could definitely
help to slow down that insulin response
as well so that is a winning combination
to me oh no she didn't
now there may be some benefit for folks
with impaired insulin sensitivity to
having the protein or the veggies before
the higher carb food but to keep it
simple for most folks i think the combo
alone is a really great start i also
have some thoughts on this meal
specifically for lunch i'm having
leftovers i've got the last chicken
tender fries piece of toast and cane
sauce a delicious nutritious lunch love
me a quick and easy leftover meal but as
a pcos warrior myself i would try to
shift around the portions a bit so carbs
are not the enemy with pcos but again we
want to make sure that we are dressing
up naked carbs with a solid amount of
protein and healthy fats to slow down
that insulin response so i would double
or triple the chicken portion to aim for
at least 20 grams of protein per meal
and add some crunchy veggies in here
like maybe some baby carrots or bell
peppers on the side for some fiber and
micronutrients no fuss but still quite
balanced now let's talk about dinner the
thing that sounds absolutely best to me
right now is a mcdonald's double
cheeseburger pulled the pickles hold the
mustard medium fry and an orange high c
maybe even an apple pie i feel like i'm
doing the thing that the moms say where
it's like we have food at home to myself
but it's for the better better of my
wallet better of my health and we're
gonna go home and i'm gonna
make something that's not as delicious
but still good i want to talk about
whether or not this sounds like a
restrictive mindset so a lot of people
who oppose intuitive eating suggest that
like people like me criticize people for
making healthy choices and applaud them
for eating junk but that's missing a lot
of the nuance in what i do ultimately
intuitive eating is not the eat whatever
the [ __ ] you want diet it's about
self-care and intention and it sounds to
me that remy is making a choice to cook
at home not in a restrictive effort to
necessarily shrink her body but to honor
that it feels good to her body and also
her financial goals so it's the
difference between i want to eat a
mcdonald's double cheeseburger but that
is bad so i'm going to go eat a salad
without any dressing at home and i want
to eat a mcdonald's double cheeseburger
but i know i can make an equally badass
burger at home i can save money and i'll
probably feel better if i serve it with
a yummy salad for some fiber and
micronutrients and we've got lots of
evidence of this kind of additive
mentality throughout the week for
example remy makes herself a delicious
looking sandwich packed with roast beef
for protein avocado for healthy fats
veggies for fiber and pairs it with a
small bowl of hot cheetos for fun and i
think there are a few really good
teachable moments in this sandwich meal
alone to discuss one let's talk about
remy hollowing out the bun well this is
a classic diet tip that we've seen on
every calorie slashing listicle remy's
rationale isn't to cut calories but to
shove things inside this little hole i'm
sorry remy but we have to brody
that's what she said
one of my favorite super non-diety
sandwiches the muffalada is only good
when i hollow out the bread if i don't
the ratio of meat to cheese to bread is
just like devastatingly wrong it's not
about saving calories at that point i'm
probably adding calories but that is
just how i like the sandwich best and
when we can think about making additive
diet changes from a place of what feels
good to me what do i actually prefer if
calories didn't matter we are much more
likely to make those changes without
falling into a binge restrict cycle i
also loved when she said since i had the
kale salad for lunch i'm not gonna force
myself to put any lettuce on my sandwich
and you shouldn't there is no universe
where the minute nutritional benefit of
putting a piece of lettuce on your
sandwich would outweigh the detriment of
now making a sandwich that you don't
like and triggering a satisfaction hunt
for something else folks eat food you
like don't eat food you don't like also
back to the homemade burgers because
they do look bomb i love that she paired
the mini burgers with like some frizzled
onions for that restaurant quality vibe
and a kale salad on the side with lots
of fiber and healthy fats another night
she had a full korean barbecue supper
because she said she was craving red
meat on her period and i loved that we
had a good spread of protein carbs fat
and some veg but let's talk about the
night that she went out into an event
tonight and i don't have time to make
dinner so i'm eating a chocolate oatmeal
protein bar this will hold me over till
i get home and i can have real dinner
not home from the event it is currently
midnight and i'm hungry so i'm making
dinner and i went with bulldog noodles
these are like a ramen instant ramen i'm
also cooking some rice cakes in here as
well i love this because it's so yummy
but also so quick to make and for a
hungry girl like me i need it now three
i'm gonna eat and go to bed a lot of
people ask me how to handle these
situations from an intuitive eating
perspective when you know you sometimes
have to eat at more unusual meal times
when you're not really hungry so again
it's important to remember that
intuitive eating is not the hunger
fullness diet so if you eat when you're
not hungry or you don't stop when you're
full you're not doing this wrong this is
about self-care treat yourself and
sometimes if you know that you're
walking into a meeting or event where
you can't so easily eat and you maybe
aren't hungry now but you know that you
will be them it's best to preemptively
have a meal or snack to keep yourself
comfortable this is an act of self-care
treat yourself it's okay if your normal
meal has to be split into two meals or
you need a bedtime snack afterwards when
maybe you normally don't it's the
intuitive thing to do to think ahead to
prevent this hangry meltdown i know
personally i would have been like toast
by midnight and completely incapable of
cooking a meal so i would have like
front loaded a big meal pre event and
had a small easy snack before bed but
remy is younger than me so she can
probably rally a lot better than me she
has a bad hangover which she is
pretending as allergies so while i'm not
sure what kind of event she was at and
why she couldn't have access to any food
at the event if this is what worked for
her it works for me now if i had any
meal balancing tips it would just be to
maybe like add an extra egg and maybe
some nutritional yeast to bump up the
protein to promote better blood sugar
control as you sleep finally let's talk
dessert so remy doesn't have dessert
every night but she does mention that
she craves chocolate and junk food when
she's on her period so one night she has
some bits of a chocolate bar and another
night she has a bowl of ice cream both
delicious choices in my books and food
cravings during our cycle are actually
scientifically proven so research
suggests that there may be a
relationship between leptin and estrogen
hormones and the food cravings that we
experience when leptin levels are low
and estrogen levels are higher we may be
more likely to desire carb rich sweet
foods all of this is totally normal and
in my opinion not something that we need
to suppress but knowing that remy has
pcos which often has implications for
blood sugar management and that we tend
to see lower insulin sensitivity in the
evening i would try to dress up those
naked carbs to turn them into more
hunger crushing combos so maybe it's as
simple as just serving them with some
nuts on the side or on top so to sum us
up i applaud remy for taking a financial
challenge to try to cook more often at
home it looks like since our last
check-in remy has kind of relaxed a lot
of the diet rules in her day and we're
seeing more flexibility in her meals her
calorie intake also looks a lot more
substantial than we last checked in and
we're seeing a more equal spread of
macros as well my suggestion for someone
like remy as somebody also who has pcos
is to aim to amp up that breakfast meal
with some additional protein and carbs
to really take advantage of the
increased insulin sensitivity at that
time of day i would also try to dress up
those naked carbs with a little bit more
protein and fat to help stabilize the
blood sugar response and offer more
staying power as well i've watched a lot
of remy's content and while i know that
she does some kind of like mukbang
content and it often features more
stereotypical high calorie foods like
donuts i don't see her engaging in like
chaotic
over-the-top cheat day-like eating it
seems like a fun activity to do with
like-minded foodie friends to try out a
bunch of fun foods rather than a classic
cheat day food tour where she's eating
all of the donuts in one go so keep at
it remy and if you ever want to chat
about pcos and food you know who to call
and on that note that's all that i have
for you guys today if you like this
video be sure to give it the thumbs up
and thank you again to storington hall
for sponsoring remember you can install
the game using my link in the
description and get a bonus for new
players infinite lives for six hours
leave me a comment below on who or what
you'd like to see your view next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]